for unit squares each have four-fifths
of their area shaded and we see that
here if we had this whole thing shaded
in that would be a whole but we only
have four fifths of it shaded and it
split up into five equal sections and
four-fifths are shaded in so this is 1/5
that's another fifth that's another
fifth and that's another fifth so we
have four-fifths shaded in and we have
these four fifths four times so you
could view this entire shaded area as
four times four fifths so all of this
all of this we could view as 4 times 4/5
well what is this going to be what is
the total area that is shaded and I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think about it well each of these
bars this right over there
that is fifth we've already seen that if
you took a whole you split into five
equal sections one of those sections is
going to be 1/5 that's 1/5 right over
there so how many fifths are shaded in
well that's let me do this in a color
you can see this is 1 and I didn't
switch the colors this is 1 2/5 3/5 4/5
5/5 6/5 7/5 8/5 9 fifths 10 fifths
eleven fifths 12 fifths 13 fifths 14
fifths 15 fifths 16 fifths we have 16
fifths sage shaded in so what is the
total area that is shaded we can say 16
16 fifths are shaded in or 16 v square
units where hole would be one square
unit but we we have 16 fifths of the
square units actually shaded in let's do
another example what is two thirds of
six well we have six triangles here and
you can see that they're giving us a
little hint and they've divided into
thirds they've divided into three equal
groups notice that's one equal group
that is two equal groups and that is
three equal groups
so each third so each of these thirds
this is one-third
of six we see that one third of six is
two but we want two-thirds of six so
that's going to be two of these groups
of one-third so that's one group of
one-third of six and that's another
third of six one third of six so if you
took both of these together you're going
to have two thirds of six and we see
that that is one two three four
triangles so that is four triangles
let's do another one
and this one's a little bit more
interesting what is 5/8 of 4 and we have
drawn here four holes this is a hole
this is a hole this is a hole and that's
a hole and we see that they're split
each of the holes is split in two
so this is one half this is another one
half this is one half that's another 1/2
that's one half that's another 1/2
that's 1/2 that's another 1/2 now why do
they do this why did they give us a hint
what we see that each half is actually
1/8 of the entire four holes what am I
talking about
well if I were to take all of these four
holes and if I were to divide them into
each in into 8 equal sections this is
one of the eight equal sections right
over here it just happens to be half of
a hole so if I'm talking about so one
way to think about it is if I say 1/8 of
4 that's going to be equal to 1/2 you
see it here we have four holes and if I
were to divide that into 8 equal
sections that would mean taking each
hole and dividing it into 2 so 1/2 is
1/8 of 4 but that's not what they're
asking us they're asking what's 5/8 of 4
so this is 1/8 this is 2 this is 2
eights this is 3/8 this is 4 8 this is
5/8 so what is that going to be all
together so I just want to remind you
because it's a little confusing I'm
saying eighths and halves and all that
remember 1/8 of 4 is 1/2 so to let me
shade this in I'm gonna do this with a
different color so 1/8 of 4
lighter color so 1/8 of 4 is 1/2 2
eights is 2 halfs 3/8 is three halves
four eighths is four halves and five
eighths five eighths is five halves so
I've just shaded notice I took the whole
4 I divided into 8 equal sections and
I've shaded in five of them one two
three four five now how many is that
total well each of those are half this
is let me just and this is one half this
is another half
that's another half that's another half
and that's another half so altogether I
have five halfs that I have shaded in so
that is five halves
let's do one more what is four-fifths of
ten and once again I encourage you to
pause the video and try to think about
it well we see here on the number line
they've taken from zero to ten and they
have split it into five equal sections
so each of this so this right over here
this is 1/5 of 10 if you go from zero to
ten
he's right into five equal sections this
is 1/5 of 10 let me write that down
this is 1/5 of 10 right over here now
what number is that well we see that
that number is 2 2 is 1/5 of 10 1/5 of
10 is equal to 2 well they're not just
asking us 1/5 of 10 they're asking us
4/5 of 10 so this is 1/5 of 10 2/5 if we
go actually maybe we go this way so let
me do another color so this is 1/5 of 10
now we're going to go 2/5 of 10 3/5 of
10 and we go all the way to 4/5 of 10
which get us to this number right over
there now what number is that well we
see this is 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so it's
the number 8 so what is 4/5 of 10 it is
the number 8